our next speaker Michael Graves is an
architect and educator based in
Princeton University Princeton New
Jersey
sorry he's the founding principal of
Michael Graves associates graves gained
early recognition as part of the New
York 5 exhibition and group organized by
Arthur Drexler at the Museum of Modern
Art since 1960 in 1967 since then he has
led his firm's execution of major
architectural commissions worldwide
winning numerous awards the 2001 gold
medal of the American Institute of
Architects the highest award that it
bestows upon an individual practitioner
and in 2012 the Richard H Driehaus prize
he's taught widely throughout the United
States including professors
professorships at the University of
Austin Texas Austin the University of
California Los Angeles the University of
Houston the University of North Carolina
the University of Maryland University of
Virginia he's currently the Robert
Shermer professor of architecture
emeritus at Princeton University School
of Architecture in 2001 he was awarded
the Topaz medallion for excellence in
architectural education a joint award of
the AIA and American collegiate schools
of architecture I'm pleased to introduce
Michael Graves
hmmm I think I'll try to stand up so
take a minute Scott Cohen wants me to
correct Greg Lin I I was amazed that
that Greg was the only student ever
graduated from Princeton without having
me as a critic now again and I didn't
design this some people thought I did I
did where to start I wanted to say oh
the first time I came in this room after
after the building was finished by
Rudolf was a amazing moment in this room
where there was a de Kooning hanging
here the full size of this wall and I
used to come to New Haven just to see
that painting the last time I saw it was
requite recently in the de Kooning show
in New York but I don't it it probably
got some pretty bad treatment here
because there's too valuable a piece to
simply leave hanging on this wall but
most of you missed it because that was a
long time ago I think I misunderstood
yesterday when somebody asked from the
audience I didn't say anything but
somebody said we have all this training
and ability now in the computer what
what is there that would ever make us
want to draw that's the way I heard the
question and if it weren't a question
then it should
and I said to myself with this
magnificent show of Massimo's outside
how could you ever for a moment think
that there wasn't a paradigm of drawing
and conceiving and making architecture
when Mario shows you the way I mean it's
such a beautiful show so thank you Bob
for putting on the show and thank you
Mario for being here I'm Mario Massimo I
brought out an article in 1977 that was
part of a published in architecture
design magazine in London and it was
called necessity for drawing tangible
speculation and I am sorry that this one
got the same title but maybe you don't
even know that yet but let's just call
it number two because it's not the same
as that talk there are little pieces of
it are and I can't help that most of
what I'm going to show you or have to do
with sketches which I call sketches to
remember the Corbusier said that we're
all lazy by nature and and we see
something in there so long remember that
and we never do unless we draw it and so
I don't care whether the drawing is good
or bad or whatever as long as it's a
notation that will allow you to remember
that that moment of architecture or
landscape or whatever it is that
interest you and why you tell yourself
these stories after after I show you a
number of conceptual titles not
conceptual but a number of drawings from
my sketchbook and other references I'll
show just a moment about a second and a
third generation of drawing
we'll be finished with that but that
would be a kind of I don't know from
them Inari drawing that that would open
the question to making a building I'll
keep keeping keeping them the drawing
wet is a worry in the terms of a painter
and keeping it open and the questions
unanswered so that you could speculate
and continue to speculate over a series
of drawings which allow you to have the
gift of yellow tracing paper or white
the ones who precedes the next and you
can see through you know that Colin Rowe
said modern architecture only offered us
two things one was yellow tracing paper
transparent paper where they used to
draw on of course opaque paper you want
to know the other
and I'm looking at it the can like a
real invention anyway I will I think I I
feel after the last three talks I'm
sorry I missed this morning but the last
three talks this is a going to be a time
warp for you it's not the 20th century
it's the 19th I'm a dinosaur my god I've
I did to understand anything I have a
nine-year-old son who is teaching me
things on the computer he says that
you're not thinking hierarchically
anyway he can just a lot of things that
I can't do nor do I want to do now let's
see I don't know I promise not to fall I
got it I got it - got it yeah yeah I
didn't design this either I wouldn't
have hidden it so let's let's get
started I promised I wouldn't talk as
long as sir cook let's go with the first
slide these are randomly selected out of
my sketchbook someday I'm gonna be able
to point this at the screen and it's
gonna go up there would you figure that
out Greg that would be a real useful
thing
anyway you can I'm not going to read all
these for you you can read them from
where you are parked more so and and for
me making these drawings usually has to
do with a kind of formal invention that
and themes of life and death and things
like that that you would find in the
park more so and here on the left is a
little house that I I stood in front of
this painting in the Louvre and drew
this picture in my sketchbook because it
was it was so fascinated me it's only
this big
it's a tiny picture those of you who
know it but it's called the Casa de
Raffaello and it's probably not Rafael's
house and the Borghese Gardens but
nevertheless here is this concave wall
that with an overhang that continues as
you see and providing this wonderful
shadow and underneath it what looks to
be a kind of sarcophagus being protected
by that concavity and I thought well
maybe someday I'll use I'll be able to
use that on the right hand side all
Annunciations share this conversation
obviously imagine you're the virgin
you're 14 years old as we told we're
told she was no wonder she was a virgin
and the Archangel comes to visit and
he's come through this opening weather
door or window I'm not sure and his wing
seems to support a tree which seems to
support the soffit of the sky all of
that pointing heavenward but his hand is
on the doorjamb
architectural element the separation now
in in Botticelli's terms of separation
between the announcement that's going to
be made by the Archangel to the Virgin
and she's got her hand on the other side
of the jamb almost a saying no no it
can't be
so you've got these two pressing against
this column of the space most as you
know those of you to care about this
sort of thing
enunciations have somebody outside the
Archangel outside virgin inside but the
inside has to be porous so it's usually
just a roll of columns so you have to
get across the columns to make the
announcement understood it's very much
like a cartoon except there are no
bubbles of other hands so you've got to
be able to tell the story without the
literal words so I knew I would be able
to use this someday
now here are these kind of drawings that
have little to do with finding things in
the landscape but after you have started
a building and are working through the
plan section elevations and so on very
old-fashioned
and here is my one of my early
elevations of the of the denver library
and usually see in the centre a great
rotunda not great but a big rotunda
which is the the rare books room and
reading room of the library and you'll
see these studies continuing I just saw
down downstairs upstairs the model of
the aspirin library that Greg's giving
this term and it's just so striking
that drum is so compelling to look at as
a place to gathering I haven't I have a
about two dozen of these drawings I'm
not going to show you that many but I do
them continuously Intel and as the plan
changes as you can see the plan is
changing as these drawings are done and
every time a new plan and in elevation
and there are towers on each am the one
of the right-hand side isn't such a
tower but you see the opening below it
it's on the street face and people
coming in there and on the other end a
closed Street between the library or
Ponte and are thought the museum is a
Ponte and our library they continue and
continue and continue until we get to
here and now you see the upper reaches
of the reading room the light coming in
held up by struts and then the last kind
of drawing that we all make of course is
the the finished drawing the drawing
that now closes the question because
probably the last thing you want is open
questions when these drawings reach the
hands of the builder because that will
lead to all kinds of disasters so the
best you can do is to make certain then
that all of these questions are
understood in these drawings and we know
the devices I'm looking forward to the
day and maybe it exists where a young
architect doing his or her first house
reaches the soffit and and the cornice
of the building and has to keep the rain
out from the roof to the wall and can
press a button that that shows him all
the various configurations
that he can select from so he won't be
sued someday this is I was just sitting
there known ago realizing this is 51 15
years ago can't believe it and I'm only
37 but this is an I show you this
drawing because this photograph that my
then wife took because I was doing these
huge drawing washes 40 inches wide and
28 inches high and it was really good
paper and I would roll it out on the
street and start and somehow I thought
that the the enormity of these facades
and buildings around required something
like this but as you see I'm looking
down and my friend Leonard Anderson came
along with me one day and said Michael
you you're doing yourself a very big
disservice if you would draw on a little
pad of paper this big you could hold it
here and look at the facade of the
building draw and not lose the
proportion which is what you're after in
the first place he took a long time for
me to realize that I I persevered and
did a lot of these drawings and I'll
show you some but I want to tell you I
realize I've forgotten to tell you a
story about drawing that that is
important to me because I often say in
when people ask about what are you as an
architect of you know people who just
call you out of the blue and and are
writing for some no-name magazine or
something
and you need to start talking about
architecture as a language what does
that mean well I tell you this story in
that I was sitting in a faculty meeting
one day and then Dean was droning on and
on and on and I was about to go to sleep
and I pulled a pad out from my briefcase
and in pencil and started to make some
marks on it and was happy with the way
this drawing was going and then Dean
continued to drum and I continued to
draw and then after five or ten minutes
I I hit a kind of spot where I didn't
know what to do next and I the Allen
siminoff who was sitting next to me
smiling and trying to keep awake himself
was looking at it I pushed the paper
over to Allen and he made half a dozen
marks and shoved the paper back to me
and then I did the same and we started
to run out of paper it's star we started
to fill it up so without saying anything
to each other it was first half a dozen
and then four and then three and then
two and then very precious marks and
Allen had reached a point where he
didn't know where to go either
and sitting to his side was Tony viddler
it was here the other day and Tony
viddler dropped in stare twice too big
and smiled and I smiled and you could
say well it's either that Tony is a
verbal type and didn't know or Tony
being a visual type which he is didn't
know and he was going to win he was
going to end the game
the game was over but it was the
language shared by two people three
really and it needed no words
it had no rules except the rules we made
as we went along to me that's the real
glory of it it's what we do
ask critics when we sit down with
students they draw a line or two and
we'd do the same and the game is on I
remember sitting in a crit with Colin
Rowe once when he was teaching at
Princeton and the student finished his
his presentation to just the two of us
and of course it wasn't what he was
trying to do it was how many of this and
how many of that he had and we didn't
care but Colin in his kind of palsy
waves but uh you could do this in a
column appeared on this and this and
then there's a wall here now look what
you've got between the wall the space
the column in its space and there's a
space behind her and the student said
well why didn't I think of that because
she didn't draw you just got to keep
drawing
so there are a number of these pictures
that I did on the ground there that I
showed you a minute ago this one is no
mediator Maria near the forum and then
on the right hand side of course
anticodon sapienza it says Alice happy
exhibit that's wrong and it's always a
good idea look it up at the top to plan
ahead when you're doing a drawing now
one of these this is a phenomenon that
I'm going to show up three times now one
of these is obviously an object in the
round and the other one is in a
forecourt presumably designed by
Michelangelo bow though nobody knows
whether it was or not together with the
culmination of that forecourt which is
which is the facade of San tivo itself
clearly in the round but giving it up
it's it's object hood to this frontal
view I don't know whether you know but
all the fountains in Rome are there of
course to celebrate water but they're
bringing the water from the Campania
outside of Rome into the city in various
places through the aqueduct system once
they reach the city imagine the city is
the kind of valley the water falls and
it falls down into a series of positions
each one of them then made into a
fountain and then it under the streets
another fountain and finally it gets
down into the city itself and people can
or did of course use it as drinking
water it's pure it's marvelous but here
again we have the finality of the Ahtna
Powell near the American Academy in Rome
and then the tree Tony found near the
bow gazing again plan ahead but it is in
this fountain of the Aqua Paulo that I
realized that why water in some
fountains looks clear and white and blue
and another fountains you don't see it
the water is rushing just as much you
know why that is because the stone
behind it when dark reflects the light
back into to the rushing water and you
see the water it's an easy lesson to
learn but it's a lesson if you ever use
water and you want your water to be
visible then you make the surface behind
it dark Pyrenees a took great liberties
with some of the buildings that he he
drew edge and here in the Basilica of
Maxentius and Constantine 312 he made a
building that as at least twice too long
you see it disappearing in the in the
Merriam's vanishing point dammit II him
mine is much more of what is there on
the right hand side the composition is
in both cases however to show the
chiaroscuro as i was so dumbfounded with
this building when I first saw it as
this is the small part of the building
as you see the I can leave up there in
the center where the arch would spring
to the great nave of the Basilica I'm
building many times larger than this the
enormity of what you already see
I took a lot of photographs when I was
in Rome for two years and here is the
imperial forum and then on the right not
unlike that the Domus Augustana which is
really the foundations for a justices
house now you can just imagine these
were always wine storage and other kinds
of places places for the servants to
live it's on but what marvelous ruins
they make leucon found that when he went
to Rome for the first time drawing the
ruins and imagining what the completion
of that composition would be like here
Pyrenees he looks into Minerva medica
and in a way I love this this itching of
his because I'll show in the last slide
today how Pyrenees a though we love many
of the things he did and a lot of people
like my friend Peter loves the the
Cotchery drawings they show construction
and he was really telling the architects
of the day how the Romans built their
walls and so it's very very thorough and
careful to show the opus reticulata and
the various coursing methods all of that
is open for us as he didn't draw these
justice picturesque vignettes to sell
which he did but nevertheless before
they were always a lesson for architects
but I always found this particular
interior of his rather muddy when in
fact my painting on the right I know
it's about drawing but my painting on
the right after kuroh shows again the
chiaroscuro of the interior of that and
certainly even if the dome were
completed before it collapsed you would
see through those windows that those
very sharp contrasts that that building
offers you this is a drawing by anger
and it is one that stairway than many of
you know they are jellies there and
there is the art of Cayley at the end I
can point to this one up at the top with
it's very curious facade and it stands
there and I think that that anger
understood that this long long flight of
stairs where nuns once a year on some
saints a day go up those stairs on their
knees until their bloody what all that
does I don't know but they do it and
into the church for penance but at the
end of that walk is the starkness of
this very peculiar and wonderful face
with its baroque door and it's simple
face he almost cancels out the rest of
the Campidoglio
with the extension of his stare and the
second piece of paper I don't know why I
bring this today but there was my stare
I even put the paper the wrong way to
show the length of this there should
have done it again think ahead
here's santa maria maggiore by pierre
noisy and the wonderful colonnade which
separates the name the ambulatory on the
side you see along here and then it look
above it you'll see that the whole table
the clerestory is gridded out and
somehow making it fragile by virtue of
the gridding of all of that and one
could dress the
- senator Murray and husband and liqueur
BCA's favorite building in Rome you see
a similar though primitive colonnade and
the wall above it with no detail
whatsoever until you get to the top with
a clerestory windows the whole wall
seems to be a piece of paper so d
materialized then it's fragile
we know look obviously I tried to use
that later I'll show you here there's a
drawing that I did of not to read and
whether you look at the side wall as in
Cosmo Dean or the end wall both of them
have that peculiar wonderful flatness
that he did to tell the story of what of
what's on the ground look at the across
the alter the figure on the left all of
that is now bound up in a landscape that
is clarified by the severity of the
walls at least I think I'm good look at
the ceiling of not react there is a
texture to the ceiling and it's a
slightly greater color of concrete not
the white as the end surface there is a
sense as in painting of rendering the
sky plane the soffit so that you enclose
and can call attention to the sky by
virtue of giving it color or texture
here he is in Raja my drawing and the as
Charles Jencks says the nones hat of the
roof seems to be cradled by a wall that
is there's not concave but is but it is
hollowed out at the top the courtiers
had said in his new biography that I'm
just reading now that he wanted the roof
to be weightless I find that it weighs a
ton but weightless I find that it's it's
weightless no but when inside or out you
see the wall the wall that supports that
roof is this thick so he's building up
this wonderful bastion of wall
supporting the the roof and the roof -
then for him is a part of the Celestra
soften on the left-hand side
Santa asana is there next to the Domus
Augustana and I should have said
Anastasia but here the building is on it
fools the eye it looks like it's concave
it's not it's doing exactly the same
thing as the wall I mean look
corbusier's Church is doing its just cut
down in the center but as you approach
it you sir start to see the flatness of
the wall but it starts to envelop you at
the same time simply by cutting it down
in this very unorthodox manner when it
paestum pyrenees a made many drawings
Catchings and most of them were
3-dimensional in the sense of
three-quarter views like the one we see
here
where you can really sense the space
around the columns but I didn't want to
do that when I was in past him I wanted
I wasn't aware of pnac's drawing but
just when seeing these these temples one
after the other lined up as they are
some of you know I wanted the
proportions and the fatalities to then
be scrims
on the stage of development of the of
all the temples because this is
certainly not the way they were meant to
be seen but they would have had roofs
and more obscurity here the Santa Maria
in Karcher a Peter this the only Karcher
II I've got here on the left obviously
stands as an object and I wanted to see
it that way we saw it yesterday
in one of the talks and then adjacent to
that just the opposite in Siena where we
see the space of the compo again now as
I've grade the sky this guy comes over
as a kind of diaphanous film over the
top of the square and gives you the
spatial understanding of it as does this
de Kirikou here where he has in the
Enigma of the afternoon as he calls it
he has made the sky very dark with a
light horizon as if it's a sheet of
fabric that can be pulled over the
square and enclosing this square as a
room the way I intended to make the
compo very near the academy there's and
a garden you pass if you walk down in
the morning as I used to do there's a
little garden
that you actually walk through to get to
the city and this garden has in it a
kind of open arm and you you enter right
at the corner there and down take it
stairs down into the city and I knew
after I found the plan of it in the
Academy library and you can see I've
drawn red lines through the central axes
of first the the pen cavity and then the
drum the little chapel next to it and
then the big chapel behind how all of
those have their centers documented by
the room adjacent to it
below that is a Justin was in my
sketchbook but since it's there I would
say that in the center of the plaza
house you see the actors through to what
was going to be a pavilion in the garden
never-was
and then on the right hand side a kind
of English garden started by the ragged
nature of the wall which wasn't built
quite like that but it was to offset the
rigidity of the central axis and to a
different kind of garden structure one
of the great plans of all time I
remember sitting in a coffee bar with
Judy de Maya once and she said Michael
can you can you draw the plan of the
Hotel de manyu and I said I could try
and being a kind of fan of French hotel
plans
I knew the gist of it because the
building has on the right-hand side
let's see if I can do this right hand
side right up here
if you enter there you'll be not on foot
but the carriage and
this whole contraption over here is the
is that stable so in you go and your
your you go up to the center you're
dropped off and thus and the stable and
takes the horse and the carriage back to
be housed back there we across the
facade of this plan and you'll read a B
C front door B a and if you go from the
front door back you see that the piece
of property owned by the family is
actually the whole incorporating the the
plan of the of the stable so now we've
got a door entering here and a center
axis in the garden which is here so
whole game is to make four rooms in
there as you see them again I'm at this
disadvantage here to get you to the
center of the composition to the be in
my ABCs so Judy and I drew it together
both like the chimú cough drawing both
adding something and erasing something
else we got pretty close and I conclude
with these pictures of the aqueduct
coming into row a little kind of sketch
that I did and from that I thought how
marvelous it would be to do a painting
which I did based on a painting by
chorim
up in the upper right and it's too bad
from the distance you are from and you
can't see the aqueduct on either side we
only see the little piece of ruin image
in the center
but here is pure nazy on the upper-left
making the aqueduct not not linear as I
have seen it stretching across the
landscape which is what took my breath
away but up close he sees the aqueduct
as a piece of architecture very much
like the Basilica of Maxentius where you
see him looking in these arches and not
the linear network at all but the
verticality of it and then the
construction and he tells you down here
about the Roman construction and then
over that construction he slides some of
the ruins this bode have been asked to
call your attention to those words and
in fact casting a shadow over the words
the visual then becomes the language
which supersedes the literal thank you
very much
okay
good afternoon my name is Sunil balled
I'm a teacher at the school I teach
design studios at both the advanced core
level as well as visualization I'll be
very brief I just have a two questions
one for one for Marion and Scott
together and then one for Greg and
Michael together before you that if
you'll indulge me with a minute and I
mean a minute just to review some of the
themes the word drawing has the enviable
treat trait of being both an action and
an artifact drawing considered as an
action is arguably more inclusive to
varied techniques technologies and
ambitions either as a means to an end or
as an end in itself both processes of
drawing from something and drawing
towards something have been and continue
to be integral to the design process as
we know from the rigorous explorations
of our distinguished panel of architects
and educators here Michael Graves spoke
of the referential sketch in preparatory
sketch well Greg distinguishes drawings
creative and critical capacity from
drafting metric burden so while as
architects we can speak of drawing from
architecture and drawing towards
architecture we cannot say drawing of
architecture without being grammatically
incorrect and since I'm at Yale with a
Dean in the front row above all I must
be grammatically correct therefore I
would like to consider the drawing of
architecture drawing as artifact not
fetishistic Lee but as a metaphorical
method of entry into the themes
introduced by our speakers this
afternoon specifically I would like to
consider the imagined boundaries of the
drawing of the page the frame to
establish the setting of the interplay
between architecture and observer or as
he relayed as Michel relayed in his game
between board Princeton colleagues
however the integrity of the frame is
broken as Marion Weiss wanders off the
point to explorations of sectioning see
reality
super positioning Scott Cohen's
cinematic analysis dissolves the notion
of the singular autonomous frame to the
point where he can claim the dissolution
of drawing as a whole and finally the
frame becomes absolutely promiscuous in
its relationship to object and
environment through the ease of digital
panning and zooming on that note I'd
like to begin with my question for for
Scott and Marian and I hope it it
engages to both view in a conversation
with each other about your each other's
presentations as well it's around the
disruption of the singular frame of
which I just spoke through sectioning
and projection which both your your
presentations really beautifully
described although in different ways I
thought each of you also discuss this
phenomenon relative to the drawings
demise relative to other media Marian
with photography and Scott with film
which introduced narrative to the
discussion particularly in Scotts paper
in your discussion Scott narrative
structure acts as an analogue to
negotiate between the difference or
sameness has made manifest in
architectural plans most compelling Lee
in the montage model you discuss while
Marian in your drawings and narratives
implied as a more phenomenological
immaterial motivations especially in the
way that architecture and landscape
integrates with each other so I was
wondering if you could each discuss the
opportunities and limitations between
projection as method of formal invention
on the one hand and projection as a
cognitive act from material and
experiential exploration on the other
hmm well first of all I it's interesting
I hate to tell you I don't really think
about the drawing as an artifact I mean
well you did say it when you said that I
thought it had dissolved entirely but
it's not so much that it it dissolved
entirely then I guess for me if we can
think through drawing to think
architecture is not to draw they're not
the same thing
I mean think through writing but what it
is we're writing is what we should be
dealing with and thinking about here I
mean I guess it would be strange to be
talking about writing without talking
about what we were writing so I'm a
little bit troubled by the whole
conversation about drawing and actually
as a standalone problem I did though
find it curious to discover that we
might think about how it had disappeared
regardless of the computer because I
don't think that really is the the point
from which we should depart to think
about whether it is here or not dead or
alive but that's really beside the point
actually strangely enough probably the
only really interesting point for me and
the whole piece that I was showing was
the fact that Vermont a needed to invent
the anamorphosis
to make the plan and that was the one
moment when you know it was an
architectural problem not let's say just
drawing it wasn't perspective any longer
anyway I guess for me the question would
be whether or not we could talk about
the way in which the computer is
apparently bringing to their problems
you know challenge as for architecture
to overcome but that in fact well
drawing may or may not have done that
the computer may or may not the fact is
those problems are inherent I think the
more interesting problems are those that
are intractable that are dominant to
architecture the dominate architecture
not those that are sort of academic and
carved out of this very special
territory
as we do it in schools focusing on you
know technique as the genesis of
architecture I don't really think the
technique is the artifact that makes
architecture I don't know I would start
with that so that a panoramic
cross-section Park I'm sorry it doesn't
really address the other side of the
equation we were referring to for Marian
which is this question of other
phenomenon that may or may not implicate
drawing which I've never dealt with I've
never shaded I've never once thought
that a drawing should try to deal with
any of those things I just has never
interested me so I don't know there we
really would differ I suppose I've never
drawn the way Khan did for example I
think much of the the kind of
cross-section of the will of engagement
that come across a lot of discussion
both yesterday and today he said
architecture doesn't happen without some
sort of pre representation before we get
there and that pre representation is
recognized in plan it's recognized in
section by those who have been trained
to be architects but it's been
illustrated by painters captured by
photographers indicated by filmmakers so
many different ways that in fact this
very act of the drawing or the artifact
is a fictional sort of thing whether
it's notational 2 all the way up to
shall we say the most exquisitely
rendered digital for sale Dubai towers
there's this whole spectrum that says
that it's still in advance of until we
can get there the architecture and I
guess the kind of postponement that I
described in those drawings for the
Stirling studio is this better
that when we reach the finish line I
hated the way it looked and so the need
to keep on going with the imperfection
very very quickly in so many different
ways led to in a sense a kind of
retroactive manifesto at each time to
find the vanishing points that haven't
been cast in there and start to find the
precision so that as it advances it way
in our case towards architecture at that
point we become very dependent upon the
computers capacity to start to calibrate
these things in precise terms and allow
them to become elastic again so I think
that this question the artifact of the
drawing is it dead the frame of it you
already said that once we can go in
motion in this kind of parametric area
we no longer are obligated at frame but
look what we're obligated to the
perception of what we're seeing through
a flat surface piece of paper screen is
still flat film projection is still flat
and so it's that flatness representing
the non flat that then gets us to the
thing that gets built and that's where
the drawing and the resistance if you
will of that particular medium happened
to stimulate the kind of coincidence
that Jasper Johns founded they'd find
with surface and landscape it's somehow
that's not part of this discussion at
all in a sense it's somewhere else but
there it is but very fact if it starts
to indicate some tactility and making
but I've got you know for example I mean
III would say that drawing it for me
that we this distinction between drawing
for picture maker what the drawing looks
like and how it would make a picture
it's so different than the drawing that
solves a problem I mean for example if
the drawing is like a plan
if we think of a plan as a drawing
actually which in a way it isn't if
drawing is picture making we'd have to
talk about what we mean by drawing
montano what it looks like
we don't read through the way we deal
with this question of drawing a plan for
example anything looking like anything
it never I never thought a plan was
beautiful for how it looked I mean I'm
sure Michael Graves has often fought it
but this wasn't what it was I mean I
love the plan where he and I Judith
DeMaio tried to you know understand it
this this is what was beautiful about it
not what it looks like anyway this is
the fundamental difference between us I
mean I think for you you are probably
invited through what a drawing looks
like to proceed to you know think
through certain things further and even
to have it evoke make vague and
open-ended to be suggestive and all of
us on the couch know I mean that's how I
think you're seeing the drawing and for
me it never did anything like that at
all it never invited me through its
appearance I've never been interested in
that whatsoever
it's really a very different we're
really very quite different on this well
actually on though you might think that
we have something in common
based on the fact that we're dealing
with making buildings a certain way that
is as we proceed to make them in the
world
young drawing well actually you know on
the note of the picture that they talked
about in your paper as well as as
something that defined drawing it brings
up I think a issue that I'd like to
engage Greg and Michael about which is
something that hasn't really been
discussed so much I think in this
conference and seems that maybe a
somewhat conventional way of thinking
about drawing aspect of drawing which is
composition
and I was struck in in Michaels
presentation about the in the
referential sketches the role of
composition as a way of establishing a
interaction between the observer and the
architecture and that as a kind of
productive conversation that then with
Greg's image reference to the Sneiderman
house event how that translation of
composition into a rigorous
investigation of geometry occurs from
the referential sketch to the
preparatory sketch as you described it
and then for Greg you know whose work is
so kind of tied into these kind of
rigorous investigations of geometry what
role composition plays in your work
you want me to leave I'm not waiting is
pretty clear Agron right so actually my
composition may be talked about as you
were doing the sketches just how you how
composition played into it and how it
how it engaged you and then how that
what you learned from that act then fed
into the preparatory sketches for
investigations in geometry for projects
like the Cyberman house I'm I'm kind of
breathless because I don't know how you
you would make a drawing without
thinking about composition no I I agree
but it's something that I think that
students and we as often as teachers we
actually neglected to to talk about
these days so it to hear you talk about
it I think is an important thing well
sure I just realized that somehow I
don't know they showed or not but there
were a couple of slides that didn't come
up one of Saint Peter's Square and it
showed a pair of columns next to a pair
of columns by peering AZ of the Pantheon
and both of them are off axis but both
of them because of airing of the columns
gather in what is there that you are to
identify with in the case of st. Peter's
Square one of the fountains there are
two fountains an obelisk and so as you
go around the colonnade of Benigni
there's always something that draws your
attention to the to the foreground
before the background of the facade or
the middle ground to the background of
the facade but for me that's what it's
all about so I couldn't do otherwise
Gregg well I mean I guess the the kind
of my response in the hand line for how
I'd like to you know shape the
discussion is that I think Friday and
maybe even this morning there was an
assumption that the precision of digital
tools is all about clarification and
fixing things and the immediacy of the
sketch is all about creating things and
all I'd like to say I mean I'm it
probably not the norm nor you know any
indication of the way things are going
but for me it's exactly the reverse that
I find what would have been drafting
tools previously to give me a volumetric
and spatial freedom and quickness that
then gets concretize more in like a pen
and ink drawing like I'll use a pen and
ink drawing to fix the stuff that's
being modeled loosely in a CAD software
and then use that information that's in
a pen and ink drawing to go back and
regulate the CAD stuff so which is just
very the opposite of what we've been
told for the last 36 hours so I think
you know I don't use vignette but if I
do it tends to be in the CAD package
just because there's 1 out of 4 windows
it's constantly giving me these
vignettes but it's the clarification and
precision actually happens after rather
before but it seems to me that you're
really suggesting that architecture
either way is indebted to technique
resent and that's it for you I mean is
that right yeah I mean for example how
are you know for example we were just in
a beautiful lecture by Philip Glass last
night at Harvard in which he said the
technique has nothing to do with music
guys no but 40 years no no the way he
no but the way he thinks about music I
mean or the way he conceives it the way
he thinks he can seize it even if it
isn't true it's the way he thinks he
conceives it and that it doesn't come
from technique like why is all of
architecture technique oh it's kind of a
second you want to learn technique until
it becomes second nature of course that
is that Arkin is it architecture the
technique itself you have to learn it
and say you have to learn it I said you
you you think architecture is indebted
to the techniques in other words it
comes from a technique for you my
question is is that what you think or we
need to have to it's to do something
else so I think it's a distance
architecture with the medium I one of
the things that I am NOT proud of is you
know the recent history you know high
temples of learning have been teaching
things like Photoshop yeah like
vocational training and I think that
shouldn't be happening at all you know I
don't think that we need to teach
vocational technique however I do think
I mean the quote about learning to see
quote I think I'm very right I mean you
have to learn to draw to learn how to
see you have to learn how to draw to
learn how to compose I think techniques
absolutely instrumental and necessary I
can i maybe add to this equation then
because I do think that what happens is
it for anybody who as I have studied a
certain musical instruments like piano
for a certain period of time you do
thousands of exercises until you no
longer think about what you're doing and
at that point it becomes your native
tongue if you will so you could say that
every media that we work in becomes a
native tongue and there's intrinsic
intelligences that move easily because
it becomes native and so the digital
media I would say for the current
generation that's learning
is their native tongue and I'm struck by
the incredible awkwardness of sketching
and drawing which I don't mind I'm just
struck by it clumsy and awkward most
people who were in architecture now and
they're very young can draw and yet how
graceful if you will their particular
medium I call it the piano for instance
because they've been doing it and it is
an effortless way to visualize and
vision wander dream effectively do all
the postponing that you could say of
decision making that watercolor or
charcoal or whatever has allowed and the
thing I'm intrigued by though is is sort
of setting aside the assumptions of
either/or truth or analytical's better
than this this is better than that but
that if we start to see that there's
predispositions of media and certainly
there are predispositions you can loft
and do all kinds of things you say
better than with that flaccid if you
describe that kind of strange thing that
you can do these very easily in some
media and not in others and then when
you're drafting you can draw a straight
line very easily because all the tools
are geared towards a straight line so
that if my hunch is sort of shifting
here at least in terms of our work it
said if we can actually take each of
these medias to their logical there are
winning and conclusion of what they can
do and then set them aside when they can
no longer do something that maybe what
we left on the cutting room floor still
has value when we move into the next
medium and we kind of like to keep them
within earshot and eyesight because they
might actually start to ask the other
medium to do something new and that's
where I was very excited actually about
some of the presentations earlier that
all of a sudden took on a computational
art form that had a kind of scatter
potential that had a fluidity and a
suggestiveness that in a sense did
everything from what you said was the
suspicious position of the perfection
and concretizing that
discussions were going on yesterday okay
I think we should open it up any
questions oh wait yesterday professor
Brothers brought up the possibility of
an empathetic muscle response when
looking at a drawing so that one if one
is a draw one could look at a drawing
and would have a a corporeal feeling as
if one was drawing that and I guess I'm
curious if the digital native III think
that this possibility is indeed probably
true and I'm wondering if a digital
native could have that same sort of
experience this might be towards
professor Lin or to mr. Reese no of
course well I'm just curious because it
doesn't happen with me and I'm wondering
if you could describe if you know what
you're looking at you have the response
so but you you can't say just because
you don't know what you're looking at
with the digitally modeled tool you
don't have exactly the same response
when you see something which is done
with an ink wash I mean if you know how
to do an ink wash and you know how to do
you know boolean composition of solids
when you see the boolean composition you
have the same response it's just you
have to know what it made it but
intrinsically there's nothing about
digital images that you'd have any
empathy for unless you produce things
digitally and then you have the empathy
for it just like perspective if you
don't understand how perspectives
constructed you don't understand you
don't have the same feeling towards
seeing a perspective they're both
there's really no difference between a
digital tool and any of those crazy
instruments Andrew showed this morning
so drawings necessarily both digital and
and hand drawings come with a certain
sense of authority to them they convey
by the convey message and they do so in
a way that says this is a it sets down a
line it sets down a tree to a degree and
I guess my question is the whole panel
and the difference between or the scale
of cross drawing whether it be sketching
through technical drawing all have to
know 3d digital modeling the question of
sort of how true the representation is
to what it is what it's trying to
represent so if we if we draw something
in a 3d digital model it it looks like
the thing it's going to be a little too
big we want to be we draw a column it
looks like a column like better than
what Michael does no I think he's way
better than a computer at capturing what
things look what I'm saying it like
there's an immediacy to it looking like
what it what we've wanted to look like I
guess well I'm a terrible renderers my
life isn't really open you you you make
a wall and a 3d modeling program and if
your pan and draw a line on us a paper
it's a lot it represents a wall but I
see it as a wall do you do you find that
the define that the directness of the
representation becomes inhibiting
intervening openness or possible miss
readings of things and possible openness
to new interpretations of the drawing I
guess like I see drawing and drawing as
being open to multiple interpretations
because it's less completely defined in
my understanding this is
well actually Michael would you like to
well no I don't know whether I can but
perhaps the problem is you have made a
good column or a really significant wall
or a wall without a story maybe it's
just four lines it's not a wall it's
four lines but when it's in context as I
showed in Cosmo Dean then then you can
talk about its nature but maybe you're
not giving yourself enough lines dan is
that question very brief or Scott I find
Scott's talk very persuasive very
provocative but it has the effect at
least in my reading of demoting the plan
as just an epiphenomena of section and I
don't want to sound like I'm fetishizing
tradition or the plan or Vitruvius but
Vitruvius certainly started his first
important tryout with the Aquino graffia
with the plan and many architects have
had the thought the myth the fantasy
that the plan is the generator among
which his court so what would you say to
this theoretical emphasis on the plan
that you found already in the inaugural
text of classical architecture which may
not be an arguable to the only one we
have the last well I mean I think the
point I was trying to make if the plan
is an after it comes after architecture
it isn't the generator of it anymore
once we can imagine it wholly so that we
can make a perspective of it no the idea
in the minute on that you could conceive
in your mind a building wholly rather
than having it only exist for example as
it did in the early Renaissance and
earlier as a drawing on the ground it
would later give rise to something else
that it wasn't yet understood is what
makes the plan with you would call de
moda moats the plan it doesn't demote it
it turns into something else it
redefines what it is I mean obviously in
a way as returning to an earlier idea of
the plan which is a variable act of
course now we're back to the
perspectival plan the plan that's after
we're back to that again I mean it
raises the question of whether Corbusier
of course is you know ahead of us or
behind us or we're certainly not in the
time that he was in these ovide this
question of the plans roll
routes to them you're really far for
routes it because of the sectional
sectional plan I don't know whether I am
or not by the way I didn't say whether
what I think about the plan for me I'm
just talking about what I think it
becomes and when you think about the
20th century success of stacking of
space which we still have as a problem I
was telling Patrick when he was at
Harvard two days ago that despite all
his curves he still collages it which is
absolutely against collage you know the
minis flat slabs that pile up and get
clipped off by his curved shapes he
still has the intractable elevator you
know he has it all that they all did
have beginning with the invention of
those things so he hasn't been able to
deal with these intractable problem I
think there are problems that are
intractable to architecture that raise
higher stakes than the problems that a
computation does when we move away from
from the problems that are intractable
to architecture in other words the
problems that are intractable to the
computation in the production for
example of Prada
you know furniture products and other
things very different than the problems
that are intractable two things you know
the purpose of the constraints we deal
with an architecture they are in those
kinds of constraints you know we really
have a different problem I mean if we're
going to deal with this medium as
architecture if you're going to say it
is architecture technique is
architecture then you know I don't know
where you are visa vie for example these
things is that or in architecture still
that we can't get out unless you just
don't deal with if you're not interested
in plants I would think you'd start to
get more interested in design industries
that don't use plans yeah no I'm not but
I would still be interested in doing
buildings I mean the problem may be no
but I think that's what holds me back I
mean one of the things about the
mornings discussions last night is the
influence of aerospace and other fields
on our CAD software has kind of changed
the possibilities of the tools and I
think that's you know Patrick and Andrew
we're talking a lot about how if you
lose the primacy of the plan
okay somebody at Boeing would when they
think about a fuselage changes your
spatial models definitely and and it
probably does cause you to go around
clipping floor plant you know floor
plates and clipping elevators but I
think that's a part of the world we're
living in is you know a lot of these
tools we made have gone into other
places and are coming back to us with
all kinds of new valances I mean which I
find really interesting but meanwhile
architecture stays behind you need to do
a spoon I mean everybody appears done
like a spoon and except you that's true
you get on it if you want to be serious
maybe you needed it you need to do it
building which everybody here is done
actually well and Marcelo after that and
then I just wanted to say that the last
three days of being a real roller
coaster ride for me so I just wanted to
thank everyone for coming in
enlightening us I think the real issue
that I'm having is that maybe probably
isn't really dead because I draw and I
use a computer and I have no problem
going between the two but maybe what's
actually that is looking because
everyone keeps on talking about how no
one's looking and and maybe we just have
a really short attention span there so
I'm not sure if that's something that
you guys want to shed some light on
because I've had to train myself very
hard to look at things without any any
training or any technique it's just a
case of looking so is it the fact that
we don't look anymore that we just so
quickly and just glare and
I think it could be a a kind of visual
savant to survival I think you have to
look at everything I think you have to
look at the place you're in I think you
have to look at what people are wearing
I think you have to look at the way
they're acting I think everything is a
part of what we do it's never discussed
but my mother once said to me oh you're
so sensitive which was a put-down and I
said thank you because I noticed that
she was pissed off about something and
and I need to catch her at it but I just
recognized it but how do you make
buildings for people if you aren't aware
if you just got to do okay
actually though there is one thing I
would add I keep encouraging graduates
to apply for the Rome Prize and go with
the computer and start modeling historic
buildings and I've been trying to get
little to do this for ten years nobody
does that's true no it's because they
all go to work for Bob Oh
no no I really don't think a lot of
people are gonna start to understand it
until you go start to think of these
things with surfaces and I really can't
think of anything more important for a
recent graduate to do then take this
tool set and go look I mean the same way
Michael was but with this new medium and
it's also from a historical and
theoretical perspective going to shed
all kinds of new light on this historic
work it's absolutely commensurate with
the architecture of Rome I mean as I
mean that would be the point I would had
was trying to make we're the
computational period is commensurate
with the perspective and and clearly if
you model Baroque architecture
computationally you are going to take it
much further in understanding
contemporary problems then if you are
reason you know you're kind of held back
by what you're limited by by drawing by
hand also the ton I mean I like going to
model of the tonay because it's all
about surfaces anyway I think there's a
lot of looking at history that today
could learn from so much everybody does
people are gentle Greg at Harvard by the
way yes they are
well Michael got something on say me
though so but anyway I think that's
really the big task is people think you
look with a sketch book and they're not
looking we have the digital tools I
think you have to do both
Cameron we was doing the best work
computationally on the Baroque that I've
seen okay there's really great things
okay well I promised Marcello so he'll
be the last question and all right
yesterday Antone's in the his lecture
with saying something around like that
the fictional possibilities of drawing
were like still in a very like early age
and I thought that with the whole
premise of the conference suggested to
me something more like you know the
relation between what I will see as a
kind of end of the modeling culture that
is such a kind of close in mediate
relationship with the object you know in
the computer that like two dimensional
aspects of drawing to me such as like
ways out beyond like possibly a new
generation of you know of work I mean in
terms of like the possibilities of
identity really cases work
pointed towards that you know in terms
of like how like very simple things such
as that a complete new space you know
three-dimensional so I wonder whether
Gregg got Scott you know which are to me
very very different ends of the spectrum
in terms of not only the world but the
three dimension or projection which I
associate more to two-dimensional have
any thoughts on that only the
possibilities of that to kind of engage
that you know just not I mean new
sensibilities towards the work ya know
I'm trying to I'm buying time by asking
Gregg to go first I really feel like as
being in the transition from drafting
with analog tools to draft in with
digital tools and drawing with analog
you know sketching and drawing with
analog I'm drawing the digital the it's
tough for me to answer that question
because I'm exactly not that person I
mean I'm a person that was trained one
way and then had this technology come in
and make me an amateur and try to learn
it so I really think it's the next
generation it's probably the wrong panel
to a set up I mean your generation which
I were close to the same age but it's an
important five years or something where
you know you you've probably learned
these mediums native in a way that I
didn't I mean I think if you're
interested in what a lot of people are
today with more complex systems they the
kind of things Patrick for example
sewing minute I don't know if he's still
here but anyway when he uh you know if
you are really trying to go into a new
domain you know thinking about
architecture through these technologies
there's no question this is absolutely
impossible at an earlier moment and so
this not to mention the fact that the
object is made you know in so
fundamentally a three-dimensional way
that you know we can't think about
drawing as we did before there's just no
question about that and that's in that
sense of that we cannot I mean it
depends what you think the conventions
are of architectural thought I mean the
medium through which we think it and how
and those particular conventions are and
I would say for example the plan is
still important it a plan despite
despite Patrick is still in his
buildings so it's an interesting
question I think it goes something
Marian is trying to talk about which is
the layering of different conventions
traditions despite let's say the
obsolescence of one and the emergence of
supremacy of another there's an
inevitable simultaneity okay thank you
oh my god Patrick I apologize but I have
to butt in at this point I mean I mean
fascinating discussion and I think that
I want to make the following in mind and
draw together some of the themes I mean
Scott mentioned we need to reflect on
not only this is drawing as an activity
what are we supposed to be drawing the
content the ambitions the architecture
which is envisions at the end of that
will determine the tools we select and
it and so that's a point one which is
extremely important remind and that what
we're trying to develop and do is
totally of a different order and
ambition complexity and richness then
what 30 40 years was the outcome and end
product and I think I want to pick up on
Greg's point that you have the
distinction between drawing and drafting
and I think there's a and we also have
the kind of discussion of the productive
vagueness of the sketch the
open-endedness the kind of searching
quality the precisely because we don't
know perhaps even yet how to translate
and and what we're looking for this it's
got a moment of searching exploration of
developing intentions and then I think
there is a moment of homing in and
running with these and elaborating these
intentions and that is not I don't think
not in every perhaps in every
individuals career to certain extent
Larry projects but more profoundly with
each generation as a historical cycles
and I believe that in the 70s and early
80's there was a kind of collective
searching of potential intentions of
stimulations of
you solutions after the bankruptcy of
modernism and I think at that point the
kind of delusion open-ended diagramming
sketching and proliferation of Poorman
universes was the order of the day and I
think the certain extent at that point
may be sketching was that kind of
necessary moment but I think it then
then we developed collectively I think
is selecting out of these kind of random
browsing collected browsing wait a new
intentions and I want to come to the
point that what drag caused drafting in
the end is also where the creative
process lies and must lie because as you
know now what we're doing we know know
what we are sparring to and how we're
building it up we're building it up with
these tools and and it is not the one
line of the intentioned sketch the kind
of vague glimpse of something where they
created creativity and trenchant and
it's an innovative creative alliance but
in the kind of next stage of elaborating
that super dense super elaborate super
filly aidid and cross communicated
project and that's where I think we're
moving beyond the kind of dichotomy of
creativity is with the drawing of the
sketch of the intention and the rest is
execution creativity I got my point
across
okay George thank you all for that great
discussion everyone here probably knows
that symposium Greek friend of mine
recently told me there's a symposium
actually meant to drink together and so
Viktor and I had had requested that
creators have wine be brought in and
couches etc and we were told to hold our
breaths for that so that will occur
immediately following Mario Karpos talk
here and and before I choose Mario I
wanted to say on behalf of Viktor and
myself to restate our gratitude to the
Dean for his unfailing support of this
symposium
- - the Miller family for their very
generous contribution to making this
happen to our colleagues who have been
invaluable to us along the way and
finally and most importantly to all the
participants who've created an
incredibly vibrant weekend of discussion
about drawing thank you okay our next
and final speaker is Mario Karp Oh Mario
is an architectural historian who has
taught throughout Europe the United
States including the School of
Architecture at Paris Lafayette the
University of Geneva and Switzerland
Georgia Tech Cornell University and the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
Williams College and the Yale School of
Architecture where he's the Vincent
Scully visiting professor in
architectural history he's the author of
several books and articles including the
award-winning architecture in the age of
printing 2001 perspective projections
and designs for he which for which he
was a co-editor in 2007 and most
recently the alphabet and the algorithm
published by MIT press
in 2011 Mario Karpov thank you
oops can you hear me good thank you all
I have the duty to be brief and I shall
be brief unless I fall asleep while I'm
reading my own paper in which case it
may take a bit longer but let's hope not
if there is one conclusion which I think
we may safely draw after today of
passion 18 interesting papers discussion
moderation and speculation but evidently
we make drawings for many different
reasons different reasons means
different agendas different formats
different tools different technologies
handmade drawings for example often
serve as personal memory aids or to
probe and investigate shapes and forms
from diagrams drawn in the sand to
sketches on paper to doodles on the
screen of an iPad this kind of drawing
will exist for either there is no risk
of extinction here the drawing we have
Jones just scene of micro graves and if
need be
the drawings exhibited upstairs by
massive Mescalero but beyond any
reasonable doubt this is where I could
you know leave and at the end we have
answered the topic accept accept but
where are other drawings which
architecture we occasionally make they
have to make to communicate with others
and to do so the maker and the user of a
drawing must use the same language for
architectural drawings these languages
often being that of descriptive
geometric now how do I move the picture
on the screen the computer expert
oh here good where do you wanna go oh
yes I see fourth thanks I go back to the
line before for architectural drawing
this language has often been that of
descriptive geometry here on the screen
and before the invention of modern
descriptive geometry that of its early
modern predecessors such as this one
these geometrical drawings have been the
main tool of our trade for most of the
last five centuries and we tend to think
that the functions and uses are timeless
and universal this is not so and the
digital Turner's recently reminded us of
this truism when culture and technology
change some cultural technologies may
actually die out to be replaced by new
ones architecture has not always been an
art of drawing quite the opposite for
most of its history in the West
architecture was a craft of making
classical medieval builders did not use
many drawings often be used the drawings
at all yet evidently they built
sometimes surprisingly well the use of
drawings for architectural notation was
a cultural and technical invention of
the Renaissance and the theory
underpinning this invention can be
traced to one man
Leon Battista Alberti who around
fourteen hundred and fifty of the still
famous book to claim right bat namely
that architect should make drawings not
buildings in a birdís theory
architecture is conceived in the mind
expressed through drawings then built
but built by others building is none of
the architects business market I should
make clean drawings and ship them to
whomever may need them
period even today this principle of
absolute separation between drawing and
building seems to go against common
sense and at the time when Alberta first
asserted it it must have made no sense
at all yet the Albertine way of building
by notation was in time amazingly
successful and among other things
created our profession as it exists to
this day five hundred and fifty years
after this florentine invention
Alberta's paradigm is enshrined in the
legislation and embedded in the social
practices of most countries around the
world Modern architects do not cut
stones they cut pencils we said pencils
they make drawings which we sent to the
builders who will follow his drawings to
make actual buildings which in the end
will be just the same as the building
the designer had originally conceived in
his mind
these are Alberti's words but that is
the theory albert is feeling the party
knew well what is all theory depended on
a dual condition but the designer may
translate the totality of a building
into drawings and what the builders may
reconvert these drawings into the
totality of a building to this end
Albert Lee developed a new and in many
ways revolutionary theory of geometrical
notations Albert Lee famously
distinguished between two classes of
architectural drawings drawings which
represent the building as it appears to
the eye pictorial drawings and rows
which convey instructions for building
or technical notations [ __ ] drawings
must use perspective
but I think Alberta should say since he
had invented perspective only a few
years before technical notations like
that technical notations on the country
must rely exclusively on scale drawings
in plan elevations and side views a few
years later sections
unlike perspective with drawings
preserved measurements and angles
without distortions today we call these
drawings orthographic projections or
parallel projections Albert they could
not call them that way because the
geometry of parallel projection did not
yet exist us is the time which is why he
Robert II have to find some other non
project even slightly devious way to
define them and he done so somehow he
could go on and claim but technical
notations in plan elevations inside use
a few Slater's sections must be as
transparent as possible because their
purpose is to convey to the builders all
and by all Alberti really meant all all
aspects of a building for in Albertus
theory the drawing is the building and
the building is all is so to speak to
speak the identical copy of an idea
notated in drawing evidently a Bertie's
project aimed at an ideal goal which was
known to be in perhaps Eva perhaps even
meant to be forever out of reach
what blueprint another term which
Alberta could not have used what
blueprint could anticipate all and by
all like Albert II I really mean all all
the aspects of a building to be down to
the colors of the carpets the model of
the venetian blinds
design of a faucets and door handles or
nylon wheels the Burton paradigm
intellectual ambition to encapsulate a
whole building in its draw notation must
allow for plenty of practical
accommodations adjustments and
compromises a gray area of bargaining
negotiation arguments in wishful
thinking but the designer can only hope
but his intentions will somehow
materialize this may or may not happen
and the extension of this grey area of
notational opacity is variable some
great architects like Mies van der Rohe
famously managed to shrink it
significantly now this drawing now on
the screen is a bit laconic but it gives
the idea somehow I don't know which
nylon wheel it was but evidently it was
a nylon wheel which means fault should
be designed but most normal architects
cannot and do not work that way from its
inception this fallacy has been more or
less consciously embedded in the
Albertine paradigm we do our best to
build by notation but knowing full well
with the limits of a log Rafi when
others must act from a script we wrote
in every performance the bill there will
be something we cannot control or at
least this was the case until the
digital came about digital designer
fabrication tools work in a very
different way when a file is sent to a
CNC milling machine and this is not just
any milling machine I think this is or
was Gregg's milling machine is it still
good so when you send a file to this
machine for example
pardon and when we send a file to but or
a similar milling machine for example a
machine just like Albertus ideally mute
and mindless workers does not debate or
discuss interpolate or interpret machine
can only print out and execute if the
digital notation is complete the piece
will be fabricated if it isn't machine
will not work the pieces fabricated is
and can only be the identical
replication of design as notated what we
see on the designers screen is what we
get in the fabricators shop there can be
no notational opacity in this logic
because no machine can fill in the
blanks or interpret the intentions of a
digital design file today today's fight
the factory design and fabrication
technologies would hence appear to
fulfil literally Alberti's dream and
heidegger's nightmare of a perfectly
transparent absolute notational tool an
unlikely conclusion and climax for an
intellectual and technological project
which started in Florence on the eve of
a renaissance and yet at the closer look
once again things may not always be so
easy today digital file to factory
tectonic technologies are successfully
used for the fabrication of small items
of a single material by subtraction and
carving or by accretion or flails
but most buildings cannot be sculpted
out of a single block of any material
with the exception perhaps of caves and
grottoes nor buildings can be extruded
by squashing building material like
toothpaste out of a tube like
in the case of a technology called
contour crafting which you see on the
screen which they claim works well to
build on the moon it has not been tested
a big building like a big machine is the
result of the assembly of many different
pieces many of these pieces can be
individually fabricated but at some
point all must be put together and
assembled off-site and finally on-site
the building site unless we build on the
moon this process is likely to entail a
huge variety of technologies and agents
and actors human and technical like
which all must be made to work together
somehow construction is not simply a
scaled up fabrication or fabrication
made bigger it is a different game
altogether and it requires a different
approach this approach as interpreted
and developed by the software industry
in the last 10 years has led to today's
technologies of Building Information
modelling beam allows for the
construction of an interactive
three-dimensional digital model of the
building itself ideal a digital
doppelganger of sorts a 3d virtual
anticipation of a building to be Lee's
model he used to put together all the
parts regardless of a provenance and to
test them virtually because before the
actual building is built in theory all
aspects and performances of a building
should or could be tested test this way
including the way a building looks in a
sense the digital model can be seen as a
building simulator just like the flight
simulators but are used to test pilots
and machines without flying or crashing
actual planes building simulation
technologies are not quite there yet but
this is where they seem to be heading
and the consequences of this trend are
momentous for the
origins of architectural drawing design
and possibly for the future of the
architectural profession as well from
its beginning and until 20 years ago the
Albert Ian notational strategy always
had to cope with a critical shortage of
processing power in the sense that
working in that way in the Albertine way
always would have required much more
processing power and any technology
could provide at anytime before the age
of electronic computing as a consequence
for the last five centuries we had to
invest a huge amount of effort
intelligence and science in order to
compress big 3d objects into small files
in fact onto flat pieces of paper
because the flat piece of paper with
flat geometrical notation on paper was
the only one we could easily record
transmit and process now we can just as
easily record transmit and process
digital simulations of 3d objects just
as we are in nature namely in 3d this
does not toll the knell of handmade
drawings these toll the Nels sorry tolls
the knell of all notational drawings
regardless of their manual or mechanical
nature descriptive geometry a tool to
compress big 3d objects into small flat
2d diagrams was a brilliant intellectual
construction as such it is timeless as
well as a compression technology we
simply do not need anymore
because today's digital machine are so
much more powerful but they can process
3d objects just as they are without the
need to flatten them first without any
compression needed
the shift from drawing to digital
modeling has other momentous
consequences the logic of BIM posits
that the making of digital model should
be collaborative and interactive just as
the making of a real building Philip
Bernstein who teaches in this school has
recently noted that digital tools
facilitate and intensify design
collaboration to add to such a degree
that some old indeed Albert Ian notions
of intellectual ownership in design are
fast becoming obsolete suggest even need
for a new model of shared
decision-making among designers
contractors and clients as of oriole
notations the traditional blueprint with
a date a name and the signatures and the
stamp on it as these are replaced by a
virtual construction site evolving in
real time while many specialist
designers and contractor work together
on the same parts of a virtual building
some parts of the building will be
increasingly designed by those who can
prove they have the best ideas or
solution not necessarily by an architect
of course this mode of collaborative
decision-making is not particularly new
in our profession nor indeed in any
profession what is new is the place
where it happens on the virtual building
side of a digital model of a building to
be with a certain historical logic the
elimination of the Albert ian a for-real
way of building by notation is bringing
about a digital reenactment of some
tools and modes of conception but
prevailed in Europe on the eve of the
Albert Ian Revolution with pre Albert
Ian physical models for example such as
vows but Brunelleschi used for the
building of the Florence dome a case
with which Albert II was familiar
but also and primarily the pre albertine
way of crafting a building on site
without notations without design but
through argument persuasion and endless
negotiation
instead of crafting a real building on a
real site we can now craft a virtual
building on their 12 site but we
open-ended process of collaborative
decision making is likely to be similar
and just like the guilt-based
medieval process which Brunelleschi
successfully tried to tweak to solve his
own of oreal ambitions this new and very
old mode of design by leadership is
likely to be contentious circuitous
argumentative and as all that is based
on dialogue argument and human
interaction it is likely to be confused
laborious and often quite messy
we know how Brunelleschi built the dome
without design other than that which he
had in his mind and kept for himself a
secret wall for the whole time it took
to build the dome 18 years but through
endless tricks arguments persuasions
deception and occasionally playing
cheating for 18 years they in day out
screaming yelling and stamping
Brunelleschi simply persuaded all on
site to do what he had in mind he did
not use any drawing to this end his
favorite notational tools were turnips
when he had to give shape to his ideas
he carved 3d models out of turnips when
he ate the turnips
so no evidence remained we may or may
not choose to use turn it today
after five centuries of Albert Ian's
intellectual and humanistic tradition in
building architecture is often seen as a
fine art today mostly unrelated to
vegetables instead of turnips we might
as well fall back on that ancient tool
of visual seduction opaque illusion and
aesthetic persuasion we knew so well
drawings we used to be good at that
thank
turning over to the turnip is gone it's
being turned into vodka and gin and
other and other lovely refreshments I
want to thank George night and Viktor
Agron for this marvelous symposium they
really did all the work I take all the
credit but they did all the work and I
want to thank our participants for an
incredibly stimulating day and day and a
half and I want to thank especially all
the many of you who have come to visit I
apologize that we don't have an
auditorium to seat the 600 people who
have shown up for this Russell - 600
people for this symposium but then again
as an architect I was always told you
don't build a church for Easter Sunday
thank you very much see you upstairs